(chants d'enfants)
traditiotraditiotraditiotraditie
e. L'occasion
pour certains enfants
de renouer avec la culture
le symbole symbole symbole symbs
fort.
Ces traditions leur permettent
de retrouver un peu de
familiarun pays enun pays enun .
Depuis le début du conflit
en Ukraine, le conseil scolaire
catholique de Toronto a
accueilli environ 75 réfugiés
sur ses bancs d'école.
d'Etobicoke, un quartier
où la communauté ukrainienne
est nombreuse. Si bien que
la moitié des enseignants
parle ukrainien.
Parmi ces nouveaux élèves,
Yuri Bokalo. L'adolescent
a quitté l'Ukraine avec sa mère
du conflit. Après quelques
semaines en Pologne,
la petite famille a finalement
pu gagner le Canada où la ait.
"C'était un gros soulagement,
lâche sa tante", installée
à Toronto depuis une dizaine
pour la mère de Youri aussi, qui
voit maintenant ses enfants
en sécurité. Mais la décisionét,
car Olena a laissé son mari
re.
je serais restée en Ukraine
et je me serais battue",
-elle.-elle.-elle.-elle.-elle.-.
Youri aussi, se sent tiraillé.
Et l'Ukraine lui manque.
- Ils sont beaucoup, comme
Youri, à avoir le coeur gros.
nts, des psychologues
visitent régulièrement l'école.
en essentiel,
explique la directrice,
elle-même d'origine ukrainienne.
"Combien d'entre eux ont vu
nes qui lenes qui lenes qui len"
se demande Lily Hordienko.
À la détresse psychologique
taller dans
un nouveau pays.
haine étape
est de trouver un logement",
explique Dmytro Saforost,
te église située
à deux pas de l'école, on essaie
aussi de donner un peu d'espoir,
le prêtre appelle
les gouvernements à en faires U.
(chants d'enfants)
ces élèves ukrainiens se
considèrent chanceux d'êtr
en sécurité. Dans un pays sûr
où ils peuvent dessiner
les contours d'une nouvelle
qu'ils ont laissée derrière.,,,,
Radio-Canada, Toronto.